[Musique]
ravi de vous retrouver pour ce nouveau
journal préparé par les équipes de tv 78
nous sommes le lundi 13 septembre voici
les titres de votre journal la
mobilisation continue autour de l'avenir
du campus de grignon connaît aujourd'hui
le nom de l'acquéreur il s'agit du
promoteur immobilier français altarea
samedi 400 personnes se sont rassemblées
devant le site d'agroparistech contre ce
projet immobilier et la vente en
circuits courts séduit de plus en plus
les producteurs et les consommateurs des
exemples dans ce journal de la ferme de
la tramblais située à la boissière école
et du marché itinérant de producteurs
locaux en ile de france pari fermier
nous en parlerons avec bruno pelletier
président de l'association et le campus
versailles patrimoine et artisanat
d'excellence ouvrira ses portes à la mi
octobre il prend la place aux grandes
écuries du château de versailles
objectif valoriser former les étudiants
aux savoir faire français
et puis cet accident qui s'est produit
dimanche soir un avion de tourisme s'est
écrasé à auteuil et près de thoiry
c'était aux environs de 19 heures deux
personnes étaient à bord elles n'ont pas
survécu au crash selon nos confrères du
parisien l'événement a mobilisé une
vingtaine de pompiers une enquête a été
ouverte pour comprendre les
circonstances de ce drame
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre la
mobilisation continue autour du campus
de grignon après la désignation dans le
courant de l'été par l'état du repreneur
les associations étudiants anciens
étudiants et élus locaux se sont à
nouveau rassemblés contre ce projet
immobilier mélanie peau qui étaient sur
place
[Applaudissements]
sans pancartes discours les opposants
sont toujours décidés à faire bloc
contre le futur du campus de grignon
destiné à devenir un projet immobilier
on n'arrive toujours pas à se faire
entendre on a écrit au ministère
concerné au ministère des finances au
ministère de l'agriculture et au
ministère de l'environnement et nous
n'avons toujours pas de réponse on avait
constaté une illégalité dans la
procédure de vente et que donc on va
s'en aller déposer un recours au
tribunal administratif
le nom de l'acquéreur a été révélée cet
été par l'état altéra un promoteur
immobilier français spécialisé dans le
secteur du logement des bureaux et du
commerce une décision qui a fédéré de
nombreux élus du territoire dans le camp
des opposants à de maintes reprises nous
avons alerté les ministres concernés le
gouvernement du fait que ce projet ne
pouvait pas être comme n'est ni sont les
élus ni sur le monde agricole j'ai
rencontré julien normandie sur plein de
sujets cette semaine qui m'a dit qu'il
était en train de me répondre je crains
que ce soit un peu tard à noter aussi la
présence de yannick jadot et de delphine
batho députée des deux sèvres et ans
ministre de l'écologie j'ai signé de
nombreux courriers avec les autres élus
j'ai soutenu les étudiants qui avaient
bloqué l'école et la décision qu'a pris
le ministre de l'agriculture parce que
c'est lui est absolument scandaleuse on
est dans un moment où on est confronté
au plus grand défi de l'histoire de
l'humanité on peut encore l'empêcher
puisque c'est pas signé près de 400
personnes ont été dénombrées par les
forces de l'ordre une lettre a été
envoyée aux différents ministres le 30
août dernier ils ont deux mois pour le
répond
barbara pompili la ministre de la
transition écologique s'est rendu ce
lundi matin à bonnières sur seine dans
l'entreprise skytech objectif annoncé la
nouvelle stratégie pour la recyclabilité
le recyclage et l'incorporation de
matériaux recyclés du programme
d'investissements d'avenir
un programme qui finance des projets
innovants elle a d'ailleurs annoncé de
nouveaux investissements scellier agathe
congo a suivi à la conférence de presse
je suis heureuse de vous annoncer que le
gouvernement va engager
370 millions d'euros de nouveaux fonds
paya pour cette strate j et c'est un
effort sans précédent cette stratégie
elle porte sur 5 matériaux que nous
utilisons au quotidien les plastiques
les matériaux composites
les textiles les matériaux stratégiques
et les papiers et cartons
cette stratégie inédite doit nous
permettre tout d'abord de développer le
recyclage des matériaux stratégiques
ce dont la transition écologique a
besoin et notre ambition c'est de
disposer d'ici 2030 des capacités
industrielles pour recycler 100 % des
batteries de véhicules électriques
arrivant en fin de vie en france
[Musique]
du producteur au consommateur la vente
en circuit court fait désormais partie
des pratiques adoptées par de plus en
plus d'agriculteurs et de consommateurs
bruno pelletier vous êtes avec nous ce
soir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de pari fermier
on reviendra avec vous dans un instant
sur ce mode de distribution et le
fonctionnement bien sûr de l'association
juste avant je vous propose de découvrir
ces exemples avec la ferme de la
tramblais donc à la boissière école
cette ferme propose des fromages de
yaourt fabriqué et vendu directement sur
place leurs portes wall le reportage
d'antoine durand et célia gars tsongo
150 vaches et 350 chèvre la ferme de la
tramblais situe à la boissière école
élèves c'est bête depuis 1967
l'ensemble des étapes de production
s'effectue directement sur place la
ferme fabrique ses propres fromages et
yaourts à partir du lait de ces animaux
et dispose d'une boutique pour vendre
ses produits elle a également d'autres
modes de distribution on travaille
sur une clientèle locale de magasins en
circuits courts des magasins de
producteurs on travaille également
auprès des grandes surfaces
mais uniquement en ile de france est
toujours dans ce même esprit de circuits
courts et de circuit local le circuit
court fait donc recettes la ferme de la
tramblais participe également au salon
de paris fermiers depuis 2018 un marché
de producteurs itinérant pour toucher
une plus grande clientèle effectivement
c'est c'est un moyen de communication à
travers une association qui existe
depuis assez longtemps mais c'est
également le moyen de de présenter nos
produits à des consommateurs direct et
non plus en passant par des
intermédiaires et le week-end prochain
le 17 18 et 19 septembre le site
agricole accueillera une trentaine
d'exposants pour pari fermier c'est
vraiment dans nos moeurs on en profite
pour ouvrir nos portes au public parce
que nous ne sommes pas ouverts toute
l'année au public juste un petit espace
qui est dédié à une boutique de la ferme
selon l'institut de sondage kantar en
2020 64% des français ont consommé des
produits issus des circuits courts au
moins une fois par mois on disait à la
vente en circuits courts et donc un mode
de consommation qui séduit de plus en
plus si vous venez de nous rejoindre une
opel qui est avec nous à ce soir le
président de pari fermier alors vous
avez entendu ces chiffres bruno
pelletier iront viens de l'entendre 64%
des français auraient consommé à des
produits issue justement du circuit
court au moins une fois par mois en 2020
c'est un mode de distribution qui semble
séduire donc de plus en plus est ce que
c'est un ressenti que vous avez aussi
oui bien sûr les choses que l'on que
l'on pointe d'ailleurs qu'en fait on
essaie de se déplacer le plus possible
sur la réelle ont menti la région
parisienne et notamment les dîners pour
essayer de promouvoir nos produits qui
viennent de toute la france que nous on
est une association de 150 producteurs
et donc on manque une douzaine de fois
dans l'année
sur pareil pour essayer de mettre en
avant est à la fois nos produits mais
aussi nos régions d'attirer les clients
dans nos régions qui sont en vacances la
boucle est donc c'est en général ça se
passe vraiment très bien ce que les gens
sont vraiment très bons pour vous
retrouver à la fois nos exploitations
pendant les vacances et les week-ends
ailleurs et donc voilà c'est la
meilleure façon de promouvoir nos
produits cdo aussi d'attirer une période
des dépliants et chez nous pas
donc pas interdit c'est ça c'est un
marché un peu vite inhérents en ile de
france et ce plusieurs de producteurs
c'est le concept même exactement celle
rappelle que je vais pas l'emmener 150
producteurs ont fait le type de produits
sains mais par contre on s'engage à être
producteur dernier donc ça veut dire que
quelque part on ne retrouverait pas de
regarder lens ne sont que des
agriculteurs qui sont obligatoirement
derrière leurs stands avant leurs
produits et vous expliquer en fait comme
on commet les transports et comment on
produit
et l'objectif c'est quoi donc c'est de
soutenir ses producteurs locaux
peut-être est en fait oui effectivement
c'est soutenir et à la fois les
producteurs locaux et les producteurs de
toute la france
parce que sur les marchés dans les
divines pourrait pas beaucoup de vins
d'alsace donc ce sont des gens qui se
déplacent régulièrement sur les sur les
salons et qui font la promotion de leurs
produits et de l'avant bien évidemment
donc notamment à la perte de la combler
on sera la ferme de la tremblay et on
pourra les clients du névian pour
acheter l'eau polluée justement
reviendrai un peu sur les prochaines
dates dans les yvelines pourquoi c'est
important pour vous et donc pour pari
fermier justement d'avoir ce lien direct
cet échange sur place avec les
producteurs et les consommateurs
c'est pour rassurer aussi que le
consommateur c'est que on a là on
al'avantage de croo du lien donc ça veut
dire que quelque part ans et nous on
peut expliquer comment sont créés des
produits et c'est issus de l'agriculture
biologique ou en non biologique mais en
règle générale le plus passant ce ne
sont que des producteurs c'est voilà sur
d'autres salons vous allez ya d'autres
vendeurs mais nous on est vraiment
producteurs et ça permet d'avoir les
échanges avec avec l'effectif qu'ils
nous connaissent qui fait de voir sur
les faire et donc ça se passe vraiment
toujours très très bien
j'imagine que sur place en tout cas sur
les salons les marchés peut-être le nom
de ce temps des limites et qu elles sont
peut-être les critères qu'il faut avoir
pour participer en tant que producteur
alors les pépères c'est que en fait il
faut que les producteurs de voir
forcément inscrits à une éternité
agricole cédant qu'elle ait des charges
de notre association il faut forcément
qu'ils soient derrière l'ensemble ces
digues à sion
et puis
après j'ai fait honnêtement je vais vous
dire la confiance des produits en
étudiant des années nous c'est
complètement envoi des invitations
régulièrement
dans les clientèles juillet un petit peu
partout qui fait que l'on trouve des
nouveaux clients mais en même temps on a
aussi une clientèle qui nous achètent
des produits régulièrement il ya des
gens qui ne viennent qui ne mangent que
par un carnet essayé il faut leur corps
une fois par mois et ils viennent
acheter nos produits nous en permanente
et justement au niveau des produits donc
on disait on vend uniquement sur ces
salons des produits fermiers est-ce
qu'on peut peut-être rappeler et donner
des exemples sur ce que sont des
produits fermiers vous disais c'est sur
place par les producteurs alors un
producteur ni en fait alors on va pour
trouver un survol sur nos marchés alors
il ya des marchés qui sont de plus
petite taille mais on essaie d'avoir un
panel de produits le plus fort possible
ça c'est vraiment très important mais
par contre un produit fermier ça veut
dire je ne transforment que ce que je
produis c'est à dire je n'achète pas de
produits à l'extérieur
par exemple je suis pas vraiment dommage
de chèvre je ne transforment que mon les
unes des pages t'aider à l'extérieur
pour
pendant les cours mal donc c'était la
dénomination fermière en fait c'est le
fait de pouvoir dire voilà je ne pense
pas que mes produits et c'est tout
eh bien merci beaucoup bruno pelletier
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
et je le rappelle vous étiez le vous
êtes toujours d'ailleurs le président de
l'association farhi fermiers et donc on
parlait des prochaines dates du salon
paris fermi et notamment dans les
yvelines ils auront lieu à la ferme donc
de la tremblay on a vu tout à l'heure en
reportage les 17 18 et 19 septembre les
8 9 et 10 octobre ce sera la ferme de
gally et puis enfin les 12 13 et 14
novembre ce sera à la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet vous trouverez bien sûr
plus d'informations sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
[Musique]
le campus versailles patrimoine et
artisanat d'excellence gers à préserver
les savoir faire le bâtiment pilote de
850 m² ouvrira ses portes le 13 octobre
prochain situé dans le pavillon de tête
des grandes écuries du château de
versailles il accueillera prochainement
des apprenants dans ses premières salles
de formation de conférences d'experts
d'exposition et de coworking le
reportage de céline charles
entre les murs des grandes écuries de
versailles des lustres au design moderne
viennent éclairer un parquet versailles
et le 18e
ce bâtiment construit par jules hardouin
mansart abriter l'école des pages du roi
il est maintenant au coeur du projet
ambitieux du campus d'excellence de
versailles il aura un usage pour
accueillir le campus d'excellence
sur une partie vient d'aménager son
pilote soit 854 et donc campus
d'excellence qui bien absorbé cinq
filières de formation
cinq filières de formation qui regroupe
un large panel des métiers du patrimoine
et de l'artisanat d'excellence comme des
tailleurs de pierre les jardiniers des
sommeliers ou encore des pâtissiers le
13 octobre prochain les premiers élèves
feront leur rentrée ici ouvriront en
quelques salles de formation des espaces
d'expositions de conférences d espace
d'orientation et puis des espaces de
coworking pour les artisans qui
souhaiteraient venir
partager leur savoir faire orienter les
collégiens accompagnés les lycéens
former les étudiants présentaient des
savoir faire ou encore répondre aux
besoins de main d'oeuvre des entreprises
cette mise en commun de divers acteurs
entend créer un réseau un lieu et un
label au service de ses métiers
l'ambition c'est donner un souffle
nouveau aux métiers du patrimoine de
l'artisanat et d'aider à l'insertion des
jeunes professionnels un campus qui est
encore en construction et qui va
s'étendre progressivement jusqu'en 2025
on va déployer sa sur les deux ailes
donc là on est au sein de me présenter
deux allèles de paris on va projeter sur
l'île de saint cloud ça va être un
chantier assez gigantesque puisqu'on va
apporter la restauration sur 6000 mètres
carrés de bâtiments à terre mais bien en
général et 6000 mètres carrés du campus
avec beaucoup plus d'ateliers de travail
des laboratoires de cuisine et puis des
espaces surprenant
et côté culture c'est la rentrée pour la
commanderie d'elancourt ce week end le
site a lancé sa saison culturelle avec
sa journée ou welcome au programme de
ces retrouvailles spectacle dans son job
le riz musical ou encore dj le reportage
de criques auricane aller avec antoine
durand
[Musique]
la commanderie d'elancourt faisait sa
rentrée ce samedi 11 septembre avec au
programme un événement baptisé welcome
objectif présenter la nouvelle saison
culturelle au grand public c'est la joie
et on a pu constater du public qui est
venu nous voir tous deux membres de
l'équipe nous dire à quel point il était
heureux qu on ouvre à nouveau les portes
la joie des artistes aussi qu'il soit
plasticiens danseurs jongleurs qui sont
présents avec nous aujourd'hui
comédienne qui en comme nous ce goût de
réouvrir les saisons et de redémarrer
cette rentrée était également attendue
par les artistes présents danseurs
chanteurs mêmes comédiens ils ont
retrouvé ce jour là la scène forcément
on est très heureux de jouer de
rencontrer les gens de voir qu'il ya du
monde et d'aller au contact du public
surtout la danse est dans cette forme
est de voir l'accueil très positif pour
ce rendez vous le public a répondu
présent avec plusieurs centaines de
personnes ce samedi oui ça fait plaisir
forcément surtout quand on est jeune de
pouvoir sortir c'est agréable ou même si
l'aïe a pas beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes
mais c'est sympa j'ai ce passe très bien
c'est très sympa il ya beaucoup de monde
la musique est bonne de se passe bien
prochain rendez-vous à la commanderie
d'elancourt le week end du 17 et 18
septembre pour les journées du
patrimoine
et après dix ans d'existence et plus de
120 groupes sur scène les vendredis du
rock de la ville de versailles ont
décidé de changer de nom ce samedi c'est
donc versailles life qui a accueilli
quatre candidats pour une finale musical
en plein air les images de patrick
jacques de dixmude avec antoine durand
[Musique]
après un concert de sélection au palais
des congrès de versailles en avril
dernier les quatre finalistes de cette
édition du versailles live casareccio
enoch telegraph et vernis rouge se sont
retrouvés pour une finale musicale à
l'ambiance détendue
j'espère que la soirée sara radieuse on
est un groupe d'amis depuis très
longtemps on adore faire de la musique
et puis versailles nous a permis de se
faire ce très bel événement et nous on
est super content on est super excitée
on n'a qu'une envie c'est d'y aller et
on voit surtout l'ambiance qui est
incroyable et ça faisait vraiment
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu déjà
autant de monde et en plus autant
d'énergie ouvert à toutes les villes de
france et à tous les styles musicaux
versailles live se présente comme un
réel tremplin pour révéler et propulsé
ces jeunes groupes empli d'espoir
[Applaudissements]
merci à dave son nez dès vendredi du
rock qui existe à versailles depuis
plusieurs années qui en fait sont
voulue pour être des tremplins pour des
jeunes groupes de versailles et
d'ailleurs pour émerger donc à la fois
proposer des concerts aux versaillais et
en même temps faire émerger des groupes
de jeunes c'est cool que ya des villes
qui se bouge un peu pour les artistes
comme versailles donc c'est super c'est
toujours un tremplin de jouer devant du
monde de jouer devant des professionnels
aussi parce que le jury est constitué de
professionnels de la musique c'est
toujours intéressant d'avoir un retour
sur notre musique sur notre prestation
scénique pour avancer à l'issue de la
soirée les votes du jury et du public se
sont portés sur casar et joe l'occasion
pour le groupe d'obtenir un coup de
pouce médiatique et une diffusion
gratuite de leur musique
le but c'est que le gagnant ensuite
gagne des partenariats avec nos
justement nos partenaires qui vont leur
permettre d'être publié et d'être
diffusé sur leurs plateformes
on prépare des choses des choses qui
nous font plaisir et donc on est là pour
avant tout faire de la musique dire ce
qu'on a envie de dire et puis si les
gens adhèrent tant mieux mais s'il
s'avère pas au moins on est entre nous
versailles live a su attirer un grand
nombre de personnes un constat qui fait
plaisir après un premier concert de
sélection sans public
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant vous pourrez retrouver michael
et demi d'euros à la présentation du 7-8
sport et puis demain grégory canal et
vous présentera votre journal
d'information locale très bonne soirée à
tous sur télé 78
[Musique]